WESLEY CORNWELL: This is
actually the second production
that I've done costumes for.
Mostly, I do set and
lighting design on campus.
One of the things that I love
about theater design or theater
at Princeton really in
general is that it perfectly
combines the academic
and intellectual rigor
of understanding a
play, or a musical
or a dramatic text, and
then the creativity side,
and the production side,
and realizing that text,
bringing it into
three dimensions
and performing it
for an audience.
Because I feel strongly
that that's what
these texts or musicals
are meant to do.
They're meant to be performed.
For me, the advanced
design class
is the perfect forum in which
different areas of design
come together in the
same room to talk
with each other
and the director,
from the beginning
saying, these are
all people in a room
who are coming together
to tell one story.
And how can we use clothing
to support the set?
And how can the lights support
the clothing, and the set help
the lights, and the direction?
And all of these different
pieces coming together
to tell different
bits of the same story
for a cohesive production
at the end of the day.